on a typical day at school endless hours
are spent letting the answers to
questions but right now we'll do the
opposite we're gonna focus on questions
where you can't learn the answers
because they're unknown
I used to puzzle about a lot of things
as a boy for example what would it feel
like to be a dog do fish feel pain
well how about insects was the big bang
just an accident I mean is there a God
and if so how are we so sure that it's a
he and not a she why do so many innocent
people and animals suffer terrible
things
is there really a plan for my life
there's a future yet to be written or is
it already written we just can't see it
but then do I have free will who am i
anyway am I just a biological machine
but then why am i conscious what is
consciousness
well robots become conscious one day
when I kind of assumed that some day I
would be told the answers to all these
questions someone must know right guess
what
no one knows most of those questions
puzzle me more now than ever but diving
into them is exciting because it takes
you to the edge of knowledge and you
never know what you'll find there so two
questions questions that no one on earth
knows the answer to
sometimes when I'm in a long plane
flight I gaze out at all those mountains
and deserts and try to get my head round
how vast our earth is and then I
remember there's an object we see every
day that would literally fit 1 million
Earth's inside it the Sun seems
impossibly big but in the great scheme
of things it's a pinprick one of about
400 billion stars in the Milky Way
galaxy which you can see on a clear
night as a pale white mist stretched
across the sky and it gets worse there
may be a hundred billion galaxies
detectable by our telescopes so if each
star was the size of a single grain of
sand just the Milky Way has enough stars
to fill a 30-foot by 30-foot stretch of
beach three feet deep was sand and the
entire Earth doesn't have enough beaches
to represent the stars in the overall
universe as such a beach would continue
for literally hundreds of millions of
miles holy Stephen Hawking that is a lot
of stars but he and other physicists now
believe in a reality that is
unimaginably bigger still I mean first
of all the hundred billion galaxies
within range of our telescopes are
probably a miniscule fraction of the
total space itself is expanding at an
accelerating pace the vast majority of
the galaxies are separating from us so
fast that light from them may never
reach us still our physical reality here
on earth is intimately connected to
those distant invisible galaxies and we
could think of them as part of our
universe they make up a single giant
edifice obeying the same physical laws
and all made from the same types of
atoms electrons protons quarks neutrinos
that make up you and me however recent
theories in physics including one called
string theory and now telling us there
could be countless other universes built
on different types of particles with
different properties obeying different
laws most of these universes could ever
support life and might flash in and out
of existence in a nanosecond but
nonetheless combined they make up a vast
multiverse of possible universes in up
to 11 dimensions
featuring wonders beyond our
just imagination and the leading version
of string theory predicts a multiverse
made up of 10 to the 500 universes it's
a one followed by 500 zeroes a number so
vast that if every atom in our
observable universe had its own universe
and all of the atoms in all those
universes each had their own universe
and you repeated that for two more
cycles you'd still be at a tiny fraction
of the total namely one trillion
trillion trillion trillion trillion
trillion trillionth but even that number
is miniscule compared to another number
infinity some physicists think the
space-time continuum is literally
infinite and that it contains an
infinite number of so-called pocket
universes with varying properties as
your brain doing quantum theory adds a
whole new wrinkle I mean the theory has
been proven true beyond all doubt but
interpreting it is baffling and some
physicists think you can only unbeli if
you imagine that huge numbers of
parallel universes are being spawned
every moment and many of these universes
would actually be very like the world
were in would include multiple copies of
you in one such universe you graduate
with honors and marry the person of your
dreams in another not so much well there
are still some scientists who would say
hogwash the only meaningful answer the
question of how many universes there are
is one only one universe and a few
philosophers and mystics like the how
could that even our own universe is an
illusion so as you can see right now
there is no agreement on this question
not even close
all we know is the answer is somewhere
between 0 and infinity well I guess we
know one other thing this is a pretty
cool time to be studying physics we just
might be undergoing the biggest paradigm
shift in knowledge that humanity has
ever seen
somewhere out there in that vast
universe there must surely be countless
other planets teeming with life but why
don't we see any evidence of it well
this is the famous question asked by
Enrico Fermi in 1950 where is everybody
conspiracy theorists claim that UFOs are
visiting all the time
and the reports are just being covered
up but honestly they aren't very
convincing but that leaves a real riddle
in the past year the Kepler space
observatory has found hundreds of
planets just around nearby stars and if
you extrapolate that data it looks like
there could be half a trillion planets
just in our own galaxy if only one in
ten thousand has conditions that might
support a form of life that's still 50
million possible life harboring planets
right here in the Milky Way so here's
the riddle our earth didn't form until
about 9 billion years after the Big Bang
countless other planets in our galaxy
should have formed earlier and given
life a chance to get underway billions
or certainly many millions of years
earlier than happened on earth if just a
few of them had spawned intelligent life
and started creating technologies those
technologies would have had millions of
years to grow in complexity and power on
earth we've seen how dramatically
technology can accelerate in just 100
years in millions of years
an intelligent alien civilization could
easily have spread out across the galaxy
perhaps creating giant
energy harvesting artifacts or fleets of
colonizing space ships or glorious works
of art that fill the night sky at the
very least you'd think they'd be
revealing their presence deliberately or
otherwise through electromagnetic
signals of one kind or another and yet
we see no convincing evidence of any of
it why well there are numerous possible
answers some of them quite dark maybe a
single super intelligent civilization
has indeed taken over the galaxy and has
imposed strict radio silence
because it's paranoid of any potential
competitors it's just sitting there
ready to obliterate anything that
becomes a threat or maybe they're not
that intelligent or perhaps the
evolution of an intelligence capable of
creating sophisticated technology as far
rarer than we've assumed after all it's
only happened once on earth in four
billion years maybe even that was
incredibly lucky maybe we are the first
such civilization in our galaxy or
perhaps civilization carries with it the
seeds of its own destruction through the
inability to control the technology as
it creates but there are numerous more
hopeful answers I mean for a start we're
not looking that hard and we're spending
a pitiful amount of money on it only a
tiny fraction of the stars in our galaxy
have really been looked at closely for
signs of interesting signals and perhaps
we're not looking the right way maybe as
civilizations develop they quickly
discover communication technologies far
more sophisticated and useful than
electromagnetic waves maybe all the
action takes place inside the mysterious
recently discovered dark matter or dark
energy that appear to account for most
of the universe's mass or maybe we're
looking at the wrong scale perhaps
intelligent civilizations come to
realize that life is ultimately just
complex patterns of information
interacting with each other in a
beautiful way that that can happen more
efficiently at a small scale so just as
on earth clunky stereo systems have
shrunk to beautiful tiny iPods may be
intelligent life itself in order to
reduce its footprint on the environment
has turned itself microscopic so the
solar system might be teeming with
aliens and we're just not noticing them
maybe the very ideas in our heads are a
form of alien life well okay that's a
crazy thought the aliens made me say it
but it is called that ideas do seem to
have a life all of their own and that
they outlive their creators maybe
biological life is just a passing phase
well within the next 15 years we could
start seeing real spectroscope
information from promising nearby
planets that will reveal just how life
friendly they might be and meanwhile
SETI the search for extraterrestrial
intelligence is now releasing its data
to the public so that millions of
citizen scientists maybe including you
can bring the power of the crowd to join
the search and here on earth amazing
experiments are being done to try to
create life from scratch life that might
be very different from the DNA forms we
know all of this will help us understand
whether the universe is teeming with
life or whether indeed it's just us
either answer in its own way is or
inspiring because even if we are alone
the fact that we think and dream and ask
these questions might yet turn out to be
one of the most important facts about
the universe and I have one more piece
of good news for you the quest for
knowledge and understanding never gets
dull it doesn't it's actually the
opposite the more you know the more
amazing the world seems and it's the
crazy possibilities that unanswered
questions that pull us forward so stay
curious